former president donald trump about to
speak at a campaign event taking place
at treasure island in support of
republican gubernatorial candidate joe
lombardo as well as senate candidate
adam laxall thank you for joining us at
six on this friday i'm brian loftis and
i'm vanessa murphy the event also
drawing critics of the former president
we have team coverage on this tonight
getting you the story from both inside
and outside the event and first we're
sending it right over to victoria saha
victoria's been outside where earlier a
few protesters did show up victoria
protesters gathered here earlier today
in front of treasure island members of
the nevada democratic victory party
showed up in clown costumes because they
tell me they believe that laxalt
lombardo and trump are also clowns
here's what they had to say well you
know we're dressed up funny here today
but the real clowns are inside and those
are joe lombardo donald trump and adam
laxalt today we want to let them know
that they are clowns for trying to
overturn the 2020 election and that the
ones who really look silly today are
them the party had only a handful of
their people come here and take a stance
their protest lasted about 15 to 20
minutes victoria saha live local now